what we have here are six different
distributions and what we're going to do
in this video is think about how to
classify them or use the words that
people typically use to classify
distributions so let's first look at
this distribution right over here that's
the distribution of the lengths of
housefly so someone went out there and
measured a bunch of houseflies and then
said hey look there's many houseflies
that are between six tenths of a
centimeter and six and a half tenths of
a centimeter looks like there's about 40
houseflies there
and then if you say between six and a
half and seven tenths there's about 30
house flies and if you were to say
between five and a half tenths and six
tenths it looks like it's about the same
amount this type of distribution is
usually described as being symmetric
why is it called that
because if you were to draw a line down
the middle of this distribution
both sides look like mirror images of
each other this one looks pretty exactly
symmetric but more typically when you're
collecting data you'll see roughly
symmetric distributions
now here we have a distribution that
gives us the dates on pennies so someone
went out there observed a bunch of
pennies looked at the dates on them they
saw many pennies looks like a little bit
more than 55 pennies had a date between
2010 and 2020 while very few pennies had
a date older than 1980 on them
and this type of distribution when you
have a tail to the left
you can see it right over here you have
a long tail to the left this is known as
a left skewed distribution
left
skewed
now in future videos we'll come up with
more technical definitions of what makes
it left skewed but the way that you can
recognize it is you have the high points
of your distribution on the right but
then you have this long tail that skews
it to the left
now the other side of a left skewed you
might say well that would be a right
skewed distribution and that's exactly
what we see right over here this is a
distribution of state representatives
and as you can see most of the states in
the united states have between 0 and 10
representatives it looks like it's a
little over 35 none of them actually
have zero they all have at least one
representative but they would fall into
this bucket while very few have more
than 50 representatives so here where
the bulk of our distribution is to the
left but we have this tail that skews us
to the right this is known as a right
skewed
distribution
now if we look at this next distribution
what would this be pause this video and
think about it
well this could be a distribution of
maybe someone went around the office and
surveyed how many cups of coffee each
person drank and if they found someone
who drank one cup of coffee per day
maybe this would be them and they found
another person who drinks one cup of
coffee that's them then they found three
people who drank two cups of coffee well
this is a very similar situation to what
we saw on the dates on pennies
a large amount of our data fell into
this right bucket of three cups of
coffee but then we had this tail to the
left so this would be left
skewed
now these right two distributions are
interesting one could argue that this
distribution here which is telling us
the number of days that we had different
high temperatures that this is looks
roughly symmetric or actually even looks
exactly symmetric because if you did
that little exercise of drawing a dotted
line down the middle it looks like the
two sides are mirror images of each
other now that would not be technically
incorrect but typically when you see
these two peaks this would typically be
called a bimodal distribution
so even though bimodal distributions can
sometimes be symmetric or roughly
symmetric you want to be more precise
and here when you have these two peaks
that's where the buy comes from you
would call it bimodal and this makes
sense because
you have a lot of days that are warm
that might happen during the summer and
you might have a lot of days that are
cold that are happening during the
winter now this last distribution here
the results from die rolls
one could argue as well that this is
roughly symmetric
it's not exact it's not perfectly
symmetric but when you look at this
dotted line here on the left and the
right sides it looks roughly symmetric
but a more exact classification here
would be that it looks approximately
uniform so rather than calling it a
symmetric distribution or a roughly
symmetric distribution most people would
classify this as an approximately
uniform distribution